Like most teas, oolong is made from the
leaves of a flowering plant species called
Camellia Sinensis.
Harvest time is during the plant's peak
growing season, which in Thailand is from May
to November. Workers handpick what's known
as the flush, a grouping of two young leaves
and a bud which grows out the top of the
plant.
At this time of year, the plant produces a
new flush every 7 to 15 days.
An experienced tea master directs every
phase of the processing.
The first step of which is called solar
withering.
Workers bring the leaves into a glass roofed
building, then spread them out in the sun for
15 to 20 minutes.
This kick starts the oxidation fermentation
process.
As the chlorophyll enzymes inside the
wilting leaves start breaking down at the
same time, the moisture inside begins
evaporating.
Workers keep moving the leaves around to
ensure a thorough exposure to the sun.
Then they gather up the leaves for step two.
Indoor withering.
The leaves lie on bamboo trays for 6 to 8
hours, where gently stirred every two hours,
they oxidize further.
Step three Disruption.
The leaves go into a rotating drum.
As they tumble, they bruise and tear.
This breaks down the cell structures,
enabling oxygen to penetrate deep inside,
greatly accelerating fermentation.
This also releases the leaf juices, which
helps dry out the taste of the tea.
When the tea master determines the leaves
have sufficiently oxidized, they stop the
oxidation process by tumbling the leaves in
a gas heated dryer for 10 to 15 minutes.
This fourth step of the process is called
fixation because it fixes the oxidation at
the desired level, which can be anywhere
from 8 to 85%, depending on the variety of
Oolong in production.
This is the most critical part of the
process because it determines the tea's
taste, aroma and color.
The next step forms the tea leaves into tiny
pellets.
First, workers shake the leaves on a sieve
to filter out the dust like particles.
Then they bag the leaves in a cotton cloth
and place them first in a kneading machine.
Then afterward in a rolling press, kneading
and rolling the bag, twist the leaves inside
into tiny pellets.
Forming these pellet shapes intensifies the
flavor of the tea.
And when the tea is steeped in hot water,
releases that flavor slowly.
They repeat the seething, kneading and
rolling cycle up to 35 times until the Tea
Master is satisfied with the result.
Then and only then does the final step begin
firing.
They transfer the tea to an oven in which it
undergoes three drying cycles of 20 minutes
each at a temperature of approximately
100°C.
This dries the damp tea, reducing the
moisture content to the target level of less
than 5%.
The firing also brings out the fragrance.
The traditional way to brew oolong is in a
clay teapot using about two teaspoons of tea
per cup. Ideally, the water should be 90 to
100°C.
Steeping time is from 3 to 10 minutes and
you can brew the same leaves up to five
times.